les voilà
excusez-moi
bonjour je suis le docteur Lily automne
mon frère et moi souhaitons remonter le
fleuve il y a des tas de danger dans
cette jungle ce serait pas des vacances
qui vous dit que je suis en vacances la
légende raconte qu'il existe un arbre
possédant des pouvoirs de guérison
prodigieux capable de changer le monde
je cherche cet arbre depuis longtemps on
s'accroche
les moteurs en quelques fois besoin d'un
peu de personne touche ce moteur à part
moi
je viens de vous dire
nous devons rester ensemble
es-tu donc pas rêvé d'une aventure
il passait sa vie à courir après des
iles et grossesse
pas
toutes les plantes que vous voyez
veulent votre mort elles peuvent tuer
vous voulez que je fasse demi-tour je
pense que ça devrait aller
on va mourir
[Musique]
allô